we caught up with Kunal at Dodger
pitcher Clayton Kershaw's sixth annual
ping-pong for purpose charity event last
night
Ashtyn Amelia were there to get in the
game on newly single Josh Duhamel was
also ready to play well kind of well I
grew up in North Dakota and we had a lot
of downtime in the mohel winter suits
got a lot of ping pong I have a
ping-pong table at my house but having
said that I'm a little bit rusty
while he held his own against ku dal he
had a different strategy for beating
matthew mcconaughey I'm gonna try to get
him drunk on wild turkey who's really
dressed for ping pong at night
Matthew was being honored for the work
he does with his just keep living
Foundation the organization shares a
common goal with curse loss raising
funds for underprivileged schools
thanks for the honor tonight I also want
to say thank you to the Dodger
foundation there's also a milestone
event
Matthew was getting ready to celebrate
next month marks the 25th anniversary of
his breakout role and dazed and confused
that was the role that at that time I
didn't it was gonna be a hobby or just
something I was doing for the summer it
turned out to be a career let's put it
all started I always look back to that
one well Matthew deserves some time to
play right now because he has two big
movies opening in the next two months
first up white boy Rick the true story
of a teenage drug informant back in the
80s followed by the drama serenity with
fellow Oscar winner and Hathaway
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]